and i think another issue is just the
culture around machine learning
and deep learning in particular
has
has tended to take a bit of a
sort of alpha or maybe macho approach
for for lack of a sort of better word
where
the focus is really on beating right so
you want to beat
the last numbers
you want to make things faster and
bigger and you know there's lots of
parallels that can be made to like human
anatomy or whatever
like oh yeah it's bigger that's better
definitely
but
and there's like a very sort of hostile
competitiveness that comes out where
you often find that women
disproportionately are treated less than
and since women are often much more
familiar with discrimination
women often are focusing a lot more on
ethics which and things around prejudice
and stereotypes and sexism
which means it gets associated with
women
more
and it gets
it's seen as less than
so so the culture is really really
difficult to penetrate sometimes
i definitely um
not someone it's generally not assumed
that i'm technical
it's something that i sort of have to
prove over and over again but i'm called
a linguist or i'm called an ethicist
because these are things i care about
and know
but that's treated as less than you know
you don't program you don't know about
statistics you are not as important
and it's often not until i start talking
about things statistically or
programming things or whatever that
people do take me more seriously which
is unfortunate
but yeah there's really a massive
cultural barrier there as well
oh you make so many good points in that
and
i've noticed that and we've heard brene
brown talk about that recently on her
podcast where he's deeply offended when
people refer to her as a motivational
speaker and not a scientist like she's a
researcher she is an academic in the
fact that
we you know you have to even prove that
yes so yeah painful and ridiculous yeah
i'm regularly called an ethicist and i'm
a computer scientist
uh i'm flattered that like all of you
know like the ethical studies that one
has to do to be an ethicist is being
imbued in me like that's very flattering
it also might be
but there's definitely just that
assumption there and i think it's
especially when you're a woman
that it really it really comes to comes
to a head where you're it's like they
don't want to see you as technical or
something like that
or they don't want to see you as a
scientist or something like that so it
becomes
yeah yeah really difficult
and to your point they
most men in the field won't pick up on
the biases as quickly as women might i
know i'm just a very novice machine
learning hobbyist but there's been
models where i will feed pictures of
myself and they've cut my butt off and
put a cell phone wallet in my back
pocket as if i'm a man wearing jeans
right yeah very interesting you know
it's like yeah yeah and that's partially
a function of of the people who are
developing the technology you know
they're just not they don't have the
world of being a woman in their heads
and so they miss a lot of that stuff
and you know it's it's true for people
with marginalized characteristics in
general so
one of the close friends i made at
google was a black man and part of why
we became close was because we could see
the patterns of marginalization that was
happening to the other that no one else
saw
so we would see that one another were
often being left off of emails where we
were the most qualified person to be on
that email
kind of thing where if you bring up
you're sort of called a complainer or
whatever
but he and i both had the life of
experiencing this kind of stuff so we
saw this happening to one another we
were able to stand up for one another
yeah things like that it's just
something that a lot of people miss
unless they've had experience with
discrimination
you